m
on s'engage sur le parcours du grand
rennes ce pour voir si on est capable de
faire
une semaine que l'on a même du mal à me
sens des cévennes et manet ou pas c'est
pas le grand raid ou vraiment assez une
partie
les difficultés se sera qu'on aura plus
de mots tu es donc les gens vont plus
trop suivre sera un peu la fatigue
femmes ministres tous qui va remonter
au début leur lait bien motivés
après comme moi ça va bien le doulieu la
lasep duchesneau la nhtsa gates saga la
presse ou fait vraiment le cored
jusqu'au bout
j'ai jusqu'au bout
durer est incroyable
je
montrez à quatre personnes que même si
si aujourd'hui mieux pas mal que je dise
que je peux pas faire ça ça bat pour
l'éprouver que qui veut peut et que moi
aussi je pourrais faire ce que ce que je
voudrais
pas les happy days of our bengué du
banat banoun apathie fils lancé parfois
du corvette comité petits et les
professeurs ont dit dans toute matière
ont dit vous n'êtes pas capable de faire
par exemple en main vous n'êtes pas
capable de faire abstraction mais là ça
nous prouve qu'on est capable de faire
quelque chose et donc balle est capable
qui est écrit derrière votre t-shirt
représente ça le défi
vas-y ouf tien minh et
enfin m'arrive la guadeloupe vit sa
guide romy
nous les